but this is what we're going to start so
we're now going to Aristotle's negative
McCann ethics book 3 and we're looking
at the question of responsibility and
choice of character right because part
of what we have to be concerned with
ethics is what are we actually
responsible for you know some people
will say you're responsible for
everything some would say that you're
not responsible for anything right and
you know people that make excuses if
there was a reason for everybody to do
what they did nobody you know meant for
things to turn out this sort of way when
bad things happen you've all heard this
sort of thing before right and what I'd
like you to think about is the
difference between these two ways that
you see very often in the media when
some event takes place whether it's you
know economic or environmental or
political managing you know protests or
policing and things like that people
will say stuff like this mistakes were
made right bad things happen more rarely
these days they will say I or we made
mistakes what's what's the difference
yeah one year we'll hire we made
mistakes you actually take
responsibility for it mistakes are made
you just saying our mistake was made but
you know there's not
yeah that's probably a good put you know
a mistake was made
we're really sorry about it I'm sorry
that mistakes were made
it's not actually saying I'm sorry that
I did something wrong you know and
people will do this though they'll say
these sorts of things even about
personal manners so think about
celebrities that gotten in trouble you
know over the last 5-10 years of your
experience they ask yourself did they
actually say something like this when
they're doing their vehicle means with
my phone right or did they say something
like this I really you know regret the
bad effects my actions have is that the
same thing is saying my actions are
going well those are you know different
ways of arranging the language right but
they actually do seem to mean different
things they convey different positions
in ethics you probably this is kind of a
sign now this isn't something and
Aristotle state but if you think about
this if you are around people who say
this sort of thing you should probably
watch them very carefully because people
who say this sort of thing routinely are
much less likely to be responsible than
people who say this sort of thing what
else do people say when something bad
happened something that somebody did
something wrong
what are other supposed to think the
people said yes all have experience with
this because you said it yourself and
you have many other people say DS sense
- you would say something like suck it
up you know get yourself up up off the
ground and dust yourself off because
life is not fair my friends say it'd be
like that sometimes
okay that's almost you know and then
sometimes people say it's time and they
did the wrong thing
how do people try to get out of
responsibility I didn't mean it it's not
my fault
usually it's not my fault is is coupled
with something like this another way of
doing is to say someone else that's out
of my control
it's out of my control there's actually
uh you guys ever seen those will be
Dangerous Liaisons is based on before
came out back was in the 90s that can
blend closest you know still serve up
hot starlet you know and it was a guy
John Malkovich was the lead and Michelle
Michaels and he is a general in France
and he seduces Michelle Pfeiffer to get
him good with the woman that he actually
doesn't care about who he is Glenn Close
who's really conniving and actually they
both are he seduces Michelle Pfeiffer
was married and then gets her to fall in
love with with him and then he breaks it
off with her he actually does fall in
love with her but Glenn Close makes him
break it off and the way that he breaks
it a lot he has this refrain that he
says over and over again he doesn't say
that it's out of my control
he was he say so I think they're similar
I can't go with the exact lie but it's
something along those lines as if again
you know bad things happen to the you
know who's who's responsible so these
are the certain things that people say
when they want to get out of
responsibility right so you're all
familiar probably said some of these at
one point in time when you probably
shouldn't have you have a set to you a
lot you're going to have the rest of
your life do people say stuff like this
when they good things happen does
anybody say
successes were successes occurred you
know they take credit for don't they
they say yeah I was instrumental to that
success my plan my idea sorry that's all
things are it's anybody saying yeah
that's how things are our company just
you know automatically produces
successful things our students
automatically learn things they take
credit America don't they I didn't mean
for this to happen when it turns out a
good go
I didn't mean for this to happen this is
exactly what I had what I had in mind
it's someone else's fault very refined
there are people there are some people
who actually have trouble taking credit
for things and they will pass a credit
well then I didn't mean for this to
happen to actually be true because
nobody plans successful yeah you're
right one level it's true but it's not
we're gonna see this we look through
aerosol it's not really sufficient way
of addressing sometimes people will
attribute their their successes to fate
destiny god things like that more rarely
than that than their failures but you're
right some people do instead follow suit
as I said even if you're not responsible
or something if you take responsibility
you actually need more leadership
probably the same okay it's not you mean
for good things are for bad thing though
for good in bed things like well you can
say no but if you could say no mistakes
are made then if you're a leader you'll
say oh you know I'm sorry I'll try
better next time rather than saying oh
you know it's just meant to be yeah
where's that it's someone else in the
state you need to say hey this person I
stopped yeah well you could say
something like it happened on my watch
I didn't do it myself directly but I
should have you know somehow this whiz
idea was this way actually make you a
better leader well there's a many people
responsible with people to take
responsibility and then if you have more
responsibility you have the better
person you'll be well I think that the
first one is correct responsible people
who take a responsibility that's with
and it's a habit you know aerosol is
gonna say there could be a limit beyond
which you shouldn't take responsibility
airsoft you know let's take for example
we've talked about this really the
semester student learning we're talking
about it before we began class I hate my
part that I'm responsible for in your
learning and so I have to establish a
syllabus come class parent get lectures
ask you guys questions discuss things
with you
there's a whole list of things they have
to do right there there are things that
you have to do as well each one of you
individually as a student in order for
you to learn and in order to improve and
both of us have to be doing our jobs if
you're really bright you could have a
bad professor who comes to class
unprepared every day and teaches you
know about their cats rather than about
the class and you could still make
progress because you would really block
and you know learn the stuff on your own
that some of my students do that's kind
of rare and I actually I'm not gonna you
know knock my way that my professors too
much but when I was an undergrad I
didn't seem particularly engaged props
for that that was a failure so it could
be that you know sometimes bold things
have to cooperate now if I just try to
take responsibility I have seen people
do this I try to take responsibility for
your actions as students let's say you
don't learn let's say only half of the
class comes out of here actually knowing
anything about Aristotle even though we
were going to talk about Aristotle for
like three weeks and there's all these
resources that that's not my fault
this was provided I've done my part I'm
responsible for a certain portion then
you're responsible because all of you
who are athletic seem to think about
this to your coaches responsible for
setting up all these exercises and
things like that but you actually have
to go and do do the drills in the
practice right and if the coach sets of
these exercises and you don't do the
drills
that's not exactly his fault of course
he doesn't do anything you may as well
just go home and play around right
if soccer practice was just kicking the
ball around no drills no scrimmages no
you know studying anything then what's
the point in doing it you just do that
the park right screw around on Saturday
so the responsibility there there is
limits to how much responsibility that
it's reasonable for a person to take and
there are some people who take way more
responsibility than they want to write
let's look at it this is all very good
good crap let's look at what what
aerosol says now Aristotle talked since
birth
the voluntary and the involuntary and
the voluntary is that which were
responsible for right Aristotle
considers two main ways in which things
become involuntary and in this
compulsion now how do we oppose that -
its voluntary
well compulsion or ignorance would be
closets for why the thing turns out the
way it does compulsion means something
else is calling the shot something else
is making the agent do the agent is the
doer making the agent do what they do
right with the voluntary the source of
the action is
the agent then the action originates
from them and you might say well that
doesn't make any sense that even if some
of the acts and ignorance the action
originates from them but in a certain
sense if they're acting in ignorance
it's because you know ignorance is a
clause for the way things turn out now a
lot of people make a lot of claims about
how far these give a block of wood
you notice the Aristotle except some of
them and he rejects some of the others
then why are we so interested in this
well there's there's too many reasons
for ethics one is an ethics just in
general right we want to know what
people can actually be held responsible
for sometimes this matters same court of
law is somebody responsible for the
thing that they did if you can say that
they were too crazy you get the Buffalo
mark right not guilty by reason of
insanity a lot of people they don't try
to make it stand in defense of sometimes
successfully sometimes successfully
right there's now - actually I'm cable
some words of that show what else are we
interested in this well think about
Arizona right Aristotle's ethics is what
kind of enters what do we place it over
does that evilness
it's not contract area it's a rituals
virtue ethics yeah so virtue ethics
makes virtue advice absolutely central
concepts virtue advice you remember
so there's a couple things this is fine
but virtue is a vitual
so it's not just something that you do
want some a while something that's part
of your character it's also chosen
chosen as such virtuous person chooses
to do the right thing because it's the
right thing and they recognize that not
just because they're going to make money
on it or because their friends tell them
that's the thing to do there is some
sort of choice being so virtuous that
the virtuous actions are in some way
voluntary now nobody has any problem
taking credit for virtuous actions it's
when we get to st. vicious Angelus that
people want to say well something else
made me do it so let's look at the
things that Aristotle actually says
about this he says since that which is
done under compulsion or by reason of
ignorance is involuntary
the voluntary would seem to be that in
which the moving principle is the agent
himself he being aware of the particular
circumstances of the action now he says
something else that's really interesting
here presumably acts done by reason of
anger or appetite are not rightly called
involuntary but people do often say this
don't think my desires compelled me to
do this I couldn't help myself
or you know I know I was in a fit of
rage and therefore I acted this way and
all of you waiting on what something all
of you have been angry right all of you
been probably intensely angry at one
point or another we had a parent to
friend sibling somebody who bothered you
you can figure the whole range of people
we get angry at people on TV sometimes
get angry out we say stupid things how
many do you have done something did you
regret later because you're angry okay
all of you has got your hands how many
of you actually felt like you couldn't
do otherwise when you did that at least
once and you found yourself just sort of
following along of course that's what it
is to be in the grips of anger think
about these questions for a month well
I'm going to put a few other things I'd
like you to think about this one
what is a case where you are not
responsible for your reaction or your
response and then write it down because
we're going to ask you guys like this
where you use these as examples said
whether they hold up according to
Aristotle it was a case where you did
something let's make it something bad
right because everybody wants to take
credit for the good things where you did
something that you know afterwards is
bad but you you don't think you were
responsible and then think about a more
generic type of case doesn't even have
to be one you agree with what's the type
of keys where we generally in our
society to all hold people responsible
for their actions
generally you can always find somebody
who's gonna say that person did it there
is one but as a society where we don't
so let me write these down and all sort
of randomly ask people
okay so let's start with the second
question what are some cases where we
don't know people responsible yeah okay
so that's like what's what didn't even
have anything like that when they're
under arrest what we think of like when
we think of somebody being other dress
we say things like whatever we're saying
we're not under arrest
it's not like anybody put a gun to your
head all right now what if somebody
actually does put a gun to your head and
takes you to the ATM and orders are you
to take out all of your money in a
certain sense that's involuntary isn't
it it gets really sticky when we get to
things like
let's say I hold the gun to your head
and tell you to push a button that's
gonna kill another person you know if we
get into a court of law
all right let's get it really stinky
what else could place us under arrest
what other sort of things that you guys
have
there could be to be like a social
duress like it's only the pressure yeah
social pressure where you know you like
oh if I didn't do that I was going to
get fired or the fighting keep my mouth
shut up somebody got fired the actual
the you know they got a job or say
financial interests or there are other
social pressures that people bring to
bear on each other at all you know
what's a high school high school best
four years of your life like they often
say to you it's not I think in college
it's better than school college working
is better than college what are the
kinds of pressures I mean think about
the way clicks work you don't do this
you can't be in this group of people
self-defense okay we don't hold people
responsible for hurting or killing an
aggressor okay or sometimes even
protecting other people what did you
have yeah yes
okay so that's as well yeah yeah we're
not concerned with just what the legal
code is because legal codes vary from
country to country country we're
exploring ethical issues yeah we don't
really oppose feel responsible for
something if they didn't have like
you're predisposed do needed to do
something
well I see so it really wasn't their job
to do like for instance let's say there
was any accidents out there on one of
the on ramps and off ramps for getting
off of the bridge onto on to 9:00 this
morning and there was you know there
were there was a truck car and I didn't
stop as a matter of fact and stuff you
know did what I was supposed to do
around temperature they actually kind of
curse the guys out now was it my job to
get out there like direct traffic
somebody should is that my job if
somebody doesn't lose gonna be another
accident there but it's not my job nor
is it your job it's might be some of
your jobs those of you are going into
law enforcement later on so that you're
right there could be some cases where it
doesn't fit into this schema dogs it's
not that's not our job
let's think about it a few other things
what about addiction if somebody's
addicted to drug and
we have an incredible craving for that
drug that sounds like desire appetite do
we in our society whole been responsible
for what they do while they're trying to
satisfy that desire for the drop that's
some time to do but locking locking
didn't say that they're not responsible
what about if somebody is actually in a
state of ignorance because they're
they're high or drunk
Harris level is not going to get him off
the block you choose to choose to have
hallucinations if you take accident
exactly now there's a distinction there
very well I'll get to in just a sec
there's a very important distinction
there between choosing the the current
state that you're in and choosing what
led up to that state Aristotle is going
to focus on man that's why a lot of
things for Arizona are actually going to
be voluntary that in our society to be
often placed in a category one is aware
of the signs of driving to drinking yeah
yep we've we do hold people responsible
for it
do you I know we do a lesson not notice
the penalties or blind drunk they might
be more willing to entertain
manslaughter charges her to Mike this
isn't that things it's not a matter of
you know no this absolutely yeah so
you're saying that nothing was done
about yeah okay was it known that they
like understand yeah there's no matter
professor rifle was a known by the
general law because there are penalties
if you could do surgery there are cases
where people go to the prison not for
the underlying charge but for lying on
the stand like that was the case of
Martha Stewart right she didn't she two
months of jail actually much the prison
yeah
your perjury so well let's look at it so
what is big nerds like or what it's a
compulsion let's look at what Aristotle
says so everything that's done by reason
of ignorance is not involuntary only
what produces pain and repentance a
feeling of you know having done the
wrong thing and the person who does it
the afterwards is actually involuntary
the man who has done something owing the
ignorance and doesn't feel any
annexation is not acted voluntarily nor
involuntary it so that sort of fits in
between no like it says acting by the
reason of ignorance
seems to be different from acting in
ignorance man who's drunk or in a rage
is thought to act as a result not of
ignorance ignorance is not the cause of
that case but in ignorance he's he is
temporarily because the state that he's
dead
unable to take in some information that
he he wants of it
yeah if we look a little bit further
down in there he talks about we do
actually plush people for their
ignorance
if the person is thought responsible for
variance so this would be like the case
of the drug user who uses drugs and they
do some horrible action under the
influence of the drug think of Lucy
John's right Lucy genex make you see
things that aren't there or make things
that you actually are seeing look
differently so I take acid or mushrooms
or peyote and now I think you're a bunch
of demons and I kill you all well I'm
responsible
aerosol is saying because I chose to
take the drug
now what do you think about it what
would you say about a case where say
somebody just put a bunch of LSD into
our water do you think
responsible for that yeah yeah then we
would be acting in a state of ignorance
so we have no responsibility so it's
really going to be key for aerosol is
not just is there a state of ignorance
but what led up to that state engines he
also talks about another important type
when he talks about vice for wickedness
he says now every wicked man is the
ignorance of what do you want to do and
what do you want to abstain from and
it's because of this that men become
unjust and general facts the determined
voluntary tends to be used not from
Anna's ignorance of West's advantage but
ignorance of particulars and now the
other thing to think about with us is
how do people actually become bad for
Aristotle we saw this last last it's
through doing actions so if you are over
and over again at your live doing unjust
actions taking more than your fair share
you know maybe fighting people for it or
you know telling yourself that that's
okay sooner or later you will start to
believe that [ __ ] and you will screw
up what we walk and call you know
metaphorically your goal promise instead
of pointing north your moral compass
will point east or south and you know
there are some people who because
they've done bad things over and over
again become convinced that that's the
right thing to do but that's the normal
thing to do if that's the case they're
ignorant aren't they they're not
ignorant of particulars the sort of
particulars that actually get you off
the floor
their ignorance in a bigger sense of
what's actually right in law but there's
fault is that
this is an interesting question
Aristotle says if it's entirely done
right well yes or no if you were to see
when we get to book seven there there
could be some exceptions to that in our
society we hardly ever talk about that
how many of you have heard the term
nature versus nurture okay good
so when we talk about a nature versus
nurture debate nature meeting some of
these genetics nurture meeting their
environment and this comes up in
sociology and criminology and psychology
all of all the the human or social
sciences
why does it come up because we want to
say what makes people the way they are
is it nature there's a genetic
predispositions that are alcoholics
alcoholics because they have alcohol a
gene or is it nurture their environment
you know grandpa was an alcoholic
grandma was an alcoholic mom and dad
were so therefore I mean sure not to be
an alcoholic
we'd often look at in terms of those two
things no notice neither one of those
there's anything to do was voluntary
free will or choices left completely on
the picture - the old beach' theory kind
of says that you know you've that a part
of you is involuntary because it's in
your genetics
yeah nature versus nurture what places
everything on the side of the
involuntary well what is their choice
will be involuntary affects what you
were talking to them so it's just what's
up nature versus nurture both sides of
it are on the involuntary so if your
whole frame of understanding ethical
issues is nature versus nurture you've
already left something they have because
you've made everything involuntary
though what's appointment debate whoa
people will debate about all sorts of
things even if they you know are wrong
you're gonna find this router College
we're here they're not actually saying
that whether it's voluntary or
involuntary they're saying which kind of
involuntary is in that case but there's
also a notion of voluntariness with it
because if it's just nature we can't do
anything about a camera other than you
know modify somebody's DNA it is nurture
its environment that person can't do
about it but couldn't we affect their
environment now if we choose to affect
their environments our choices are
actually voluntary so the this whole
notion of nurture versus nature
it's very incompletely would have to be
in that what else be added to that is
the voluntary the whole sphere where we
actually choose to do things yeah
listen if you like nature you can't
really you don't have a good charger
genetics would nurture you have control
over your environment you can okay this
meat components are your choice to say
okay you know I'm going to hang out with
a different social reporter then we do
get a different job oh you're right at a
certain point when you were when you
were a kid you didn't choose what sort
of household you were in but part of the
process of becoming an adolescent and
then an adult is actually things like
choosing your peer group although you
know again you don't have absolute
you can really that control your
environment sometimes it depends on that
would somebody be how yes you're right
you're unifying them we're gonna get
into this a little bit later a lot of
ethics is what you make of imperfect
situations well what's going on with
ignorance so when could ignorant
actually get us off more aerosol lays
down some particular circumstances that
we might be ignorant he says a man like
the ignorant who he is but it's doing
what are who he's acting on sometimes
also one is doing it with and to what
end and how he's doing it he says nobody
could actually the ignorance of all
these unless it's crazy it's very rare
when the person is actually the
ignorance of who they are what it does
happen so he wants to be very you know
exhausted asleep that's it in there well
let's think about some of these other
ways of what he's doing a man might be
ignorant as for instance when people say
it slipped out of their mouths as they
were speaking here where they did not
know it was a secret
there could be certainly actions that
when we do them we think we're doing one
thing but because of the circumstances
that we're in we don't realize that
we're actually doing something else as
well
so I think that I am just driving my car
at night and it turns out that I didn't
realize it but I was running over all
sorts of Possible's
and I may not have intended that that
may not have been the description that I
gave it my action but that could be the
result of it right so that would be what
the
yes I merely intended to give
constructive criticism but in the
process I destroyed somebody's
self-esteem acting in ignorance didn't
realize that the person was so friendly
you know I didn't realize that their
their parents have both died in a
terrible car crash the night before and
that you know my criticizing their their
paper was going to send them over the
edge that would be acting by reason
that's the reason you couldn't be you
couldn't know all the particulars what
else we give you some examples like you
might think that think that your dear
son was it was an enemy people get mixed
up about all these sorts of things they
think that they're their friends are you
know trying to steal their boyfriend or
girl or are out to get them you'll get
paranoid about these sort of things
sometimes appointed spearhead upon I
thought maybe it was walked right in old
days people used to practice martial
arts with real weapons
there's blunt base defense actually and
then you know fencing is you know
fighting the swords that not quite like
real swords but they hurt like hell when
you get with them and if you took the
tip off but you can kill somebody it was
pretty easily do you think people
actually set about to do that too
literally well maybe some but most
people don't but accidents happen right
it was running with the scissors I
didn't realize they were so sharp until
I ran into something that's not
something
just an example but it's an example that
that business you might give a man a
draught the drink of water to save him
but actually kill them you might want to
touch a man as people do as far as using
the martial arts example and they
actually hurt him so you might not be
aware or just how strong anymore
you know there's a lot of possibilities
where you would be ignorant of some sort
of particular reaction and then it would
be involuntary wouldn't it provided
you're not the cause of that that
ignorance then let's look now at
compulsion so what actually be called
compulsory we answer that without
qualification actions are so with the
clauses in the external circumstances
and not engagement and things that are
the things that are in themselves with
voluntary then but now in return for
these gains are worthy of choice it was
moving principles the agents are in
themselves involuntary so in one way
they're involuntary but in return for
the games are our volunteers so if you
if you do something for money like to
hold on to your job right if you don't
make sure that my shoes are shined every
day then I'm gonna fire in one sense you
shining my shoes is involuntary you're
doing it under duress as we say these
little choice you just happen to prefer
keeping your job more than not shining
shoes and you can even say that with the
ATM
a gun on your head example although
that's a lot harder choice and Aristotle
says something really interesting
he says there's certain limits that
beyond which we don't hold people
responsible I think a gun to your head
is probably one of the limits or you
don't call straight people on her dress
and torture us people do that to give up
information torture isn't really that
effective the people say also there's
all sorts of ways to but to us
now we're dolls does this become an
issue it's pretty rare that somebody is
the cause of somebody else using
compulsion on them it's pretty common
that somebody is the cause of their own
ignorance though so that would if you're
the cause of that if the chain goes like
this the agents ignorant then the agent
acting in ignorance the agent is
responsible that's voluntary so if you
get yourself drunk you know when you do
something you are ignorant of what
you're doing but you chose to get drunk
if you
once you have a vicious character and if
you have no moral compass mixed up it's
to some degree because you develop that
Harris level houses something else if
that's the case can we just fix it very
well just towards the end of that
section three the first was talking
about the particular virtues then so
there's good news and bad news the good
news is when it comes to virtues once
you've actually established a virtue
you're you're sort of on a trajectory
you have inertia you're going to keep
doing that you're going to keep doing
the right thing at the right time for
the right reason bad news is once you
did that with Vice you're going to keep
going on that same trajectory - it's not
easy to change it you have to make a
deliberate effort to break one habit and
replace it with another DEATH so if you
are for instance let's think of a very
common example in our society there's
huge Lisa T is that epidemic in our
society they call it an epidemic you
know it's not quite the same things with
disease but it is actually a problem
it's got an economic effects is leading
to all sorts of changes in things it's
big problem especially for younger kids
why don't you believe too much that's a
question where you can ask whether it's
voluntary or involuntary when people
over eat it could be because they have
you know an insatiable compulsion and
they just can't stop eating that's
pretty rare it's more often because
but Aristotle calls self-indulgence that
they are the opposite of 1.71 the
opposite of temperate temperance is the
virtue that he has to do with how we
regulate we talked about this Plato how
we regulate our bodily pleasures eating
and drinking our bodily pleasures right
you want to take the right amount at the
right time for the right reason if
you're eating all the time and you're
eating more than you want to that's a
problem that's actually an advice the
person who does that
they actually quite often think that
that's the right amount for them they
they become ignorant of what their good
actually is you know think about a real
easy example should you eat before you
go to bed weight off from your health
classes why is it a bad idea to eat
before you go to bed others might give
you bad dreams
metabolism slows before you go when
you're sleeping yeah so you know what do
we eat before we go to bed you know it's
usually a midnight snack and there's
gonna be something healthy like a salad
I'm gonna make myself a salad before I
go to bed another watching TV and they
need some popcorn or chips or you know
wash it down with soda you're not gonna
burn those calories off while you're
sleeping right
so is it is it a good move for you to do
that people you know over and over again
lose sight of that I mean if you
actually quit an optimist II probably
shouldn't do that maybe they wouldn't be
an ignorance
why are they in ignorance it's because
of the vices because they you can't just
tell yourself okay
I'm gonna change like that quit being
vicious and start being virtuous
it has to change action after action
after action after action how do you
change it when it comes to eating one
meal at a time one snack at a time you
know you go over to the cafeteria and
instead of getting you know a really big
portion you get a smaller portion you do
that often enough you'll become
temperate you do the opposite off and
off you will become self-indulgent
Aristotle says yes there aren't you that
are correct about that although the
majority of people who are overweight in
our society Western society in general
they're already a director some people
over know hormone imbalances it's much
less common than what we're talking
about here there are some actually yes
Aristotle would say you know if you have
some sort of bodily and balance that's
not volunteerism you're any control you
would have control over whether you
taking medicine in our society the last
thing that I want to get
moral choice and deliberation this is
going to take us one step further so up
to this point we've been talking about
this voluntary and what's involuntary
now there's a class of the voluntary
that has to do with weight loss moral
choice so here is the realm of voluntary
actions sometimes it's translated
liberabit choice sometimes it's
translated this choice like I put into
your I learn thing it's actually
translating a Greek term that's a bit
difficult to translate well pro at races
which means literally preference or
selection or choosing but it has a sort
of habitual done over and over again
kind of connotation to it so your prior
asus is responsible for the character
that you have in a large sense you're
your pro a racist is that whole battery
of your dispositions and habits that you
developed it's what you are it's what I
am
yeah so you're talking about the trilogy
it's something about a conscious choice
certain yeah it kind of just one base
time have it well they can't become
unconscious based on the habit later on
but you know it's our conscious choices
that actually do establish cats and all
the moral choices volunteer not
everything volunteer is is necessarily
more choice so moral choice is that
sphere that we actually have control and
we deliberate
now you probably don't use this urn for
describing what it is that you actually
do when you're faced with a bunch of
choices you don't say I'm going to go to
deliberate you say things like I'm going
to sleep on that I'm gonna go talk to
some friends I need to think this board
when you're thinking something over what
you're doing Aristotle says is you're
actually like laying out the different
possibilities and seeing you know which
ones would actually satisfy your
interest your desires your as he calls
it ends the most deliberation is how we
get to our heads our rules the things
that we want the most so when you're in
a situation your ends can change too
from time to time you know it's going to
depend on the situation so your end as
you go out on a Saturday night may be to
not be lonely or to find sexual partner
or they have a good time these are three
possible madness' right that all could
fit within the matrix of going out on
Saturday night and there are certain
things that would be means for them
right and they may be connected in a
little chain and everything that you do
your whole life everything that
everybody else does they've got some
ends they've got some goals in mind
right you could have multiple we usually
do now when you actually have to sit
down and think about things make moral
choices you're not deciding which ends
you want to pursue you've already got an
end in mind you're trying to figure out
which means are the best means to get
yourself
do the means interfere with other things
that are important for you you know
what's something that's that's important
you think for all of you as students
some you all might graduate right so
you'll do what it takes to graduate oh
right
anybody who won't do what it takes to
graduate all of you are on the path to
graduation you have to think about what
you're going to do let's think of not
you know all choice what classes are you
take should you take just two classes
that you find the most interesting by
their descriptions does that recipe for
graduating you guys have advisors right
if any have ever gone into your advisor
if you say all right here's what I want
to take this class this class in this
class your advisor says well you can
have one of those but you you have to
take this and this and this this
semester at Stax do you not I guess why
do they do that so you sure you graduate
someone all the time yeah because if you
chose the means that you want maybe you
will graduate you can stop and you small
the academic flowers maybe a less this
you know stay an extra semester that
might actually be a good thing you could
actually deliberate with yourself maybe
I do want to stay an extra semester so I
can take some more classes but now you
have a different end in life don't you
now you're not residing where they're
graduating out of time
deeper desires that you have and
oftentimes as you think about this sort
of stuff where you talk it over with
other people you will uncover what it is
that you care about this happens in
relationships too you get into an
argument with your significant other
what do you generally want to do in an
arc is that the shop that could be fun
some people like breaking things do
things around you prove a point right
and the reason why you're having an
argument is another person how do they
feel about your point you know they
don't like they don't agree with it they
have their own point that they usually
directly opposed to your point that they
are trying to prove as well
have you ever stopped in the middle of
an argument they have thought about what
you're actually doing
yeah yes what sort of thoughts go
through your head
you have to be the you're mistaken about
things it's possible to put it in a
bigger picture and say should should
really be yelling at the person that I
supposedly care about do it really one
of the Haven swords this the pattern
that I want to hang out with this person
who maybe I'll be together with for the
rest of my life if you're doing that
what you're doing is you're actually
reconsidering you're trying to find what
your altima that is and then you're
thinking you know these means our early
good means I better find some other
means to attain that now like maybe
entertaining whether they could be
correct or not if what really matters to
you is winning
you're not gonna entertain what's that
you'd be correct right they're not
correct because you're correct and
that's it if you care about the person
and you care about your relationship
with the person or are you even yeah
maybe you don't actually care about the
person
maybe you just care about you actually
not feeling like you're correct but
actually being correct maybe is that a
necessary means to that is actually
listening to the other person we notice
that if you have different ends you're
going to select different means somebody
is basically going to say that you know
maybe when you're arguing mm-hmm maybe
when it stopped I think that you know
maybe it's not really important that
they feel the same way I do and then you
change your ends kind of by saying
already I don't need to convince this
person that I'm right yeah
well that word that could be changing
the means along the way okay do I really
need to we often get mistaken we have an
end in mind who said I have to have this
means we're also I can't have that up we
don't often realize that there could be
multiple ways to get to the same same
goal right there's a few other things
that Aristotle says that I don't want to
get up he says do we deliberate about
everything no we don't deliberate about
everything what don't we deliberate
about well we don't deliberate about
things that are not in our power do we
deliberate about what the Chinese Prime
Minister is going to do we might
deliberate about what we're trying to
predict it for Chinese pundits but for
the most part no we don't it's not
within our powers it's not in our scope
do we deliberate about whether corn
grows best if you put herbicide on the
seed or whether you spray down fields or
we do organic gardening that's not
actually a deliberation that's not
figuring out what the the heads are
that's that's you know discussions about
Natural Science deliberation Leakey says
is about things that are in our power
and and can be done that we actually
have some choice of them it's concerned
with things that happen in a certain way
for the most part but which in which the
event is obscured with with things in
which it is in determine ethics is not
about things being perfectly definable
the reason why we study ethics is to
deal with all these sorts of cases where
or that originally we talked about being
a gray area to try to no disentangle
some of the black
out of it even after we do that though
we're not left with the perfect
distinction between them there there are
still going to be some cases where you
could deliver it several different ways
and get to the same and now what's very
important here would connects us all
together this has to do with our
character this is the process of
practical reason deliberation is
practical reasoning here is where our
characters if we practically reason
well our character will improve over
time because as we do with things we
become better people as we do just the
actions which you know we do just
actions because we realize that's the
right thing to do that that is what will
actually satisfy the ends that we have
if we do temporary actions so if we do
courageous actions we will become
temperate and courageous so the ways in
which and not just we do things with the
ways in which we think about things and
what we accept from other people with
their thinking about things that's gonna
affect our character likewise once you
actually establish a character that will
lead to certain modes of practical
reasoning the unjust person why do you
have to watch out for them because they
are going to practically resume in such
a way as to screw you over
and screw over everybody else if they
can that's what it means to be unjust
that they have a disposition to doing
that kind of thing the coward you know
that you bring along with you to watch
your back whether it's a right situation
we're going into a difficult
negotiation we're dealing with somebody
that you don't like to talk to when you
have to their character is going to lead
them to practically reason in such a way
it has to let you down so these are very
important these are interrelated the way
in which we think about this the way we
practically reason you guys are doing
this all the time and your character are
interconnected yeah so instead of from
habits so if I think most of the reason
why people put things into a gray area
yeah who's a lot of hard decisions are
time sensitive and at that time oh yeah
we don't develop the habit or skill
maybe we're not put in this situation
about we make the wrong decision
sometimes yeah I don't think you really
you know it's kind of voluntary but it's
also kind of involuntary that you as
well because later on you think II can't
find more time to think about I would
have done something different you're
right yeah I mean that could be acting
in it in ignorance of the particulars
and you're right ethics is about making
decisions within concrete situations in
which we never have perfect knowledge
they don't often look like our textbook
cases tells you know what having the
time and there's really only thing
that's why heaven is so important though
you lay down for yourself what the
future is going to look like
with the decisions that you're making
now so if you if you want to be a just
person when you actually run into stinky
up into situations where you're gonna
have to make decisions and you're not
going to have a full knowledge and
there's gonna be pressure severe you
have to start doing adjust the actions
now according to Aristotle so that you
will be able to practically reason well
when you get to that it's not enough
just to look knowledge about this you
actually have to practice same thing
with courage read Aristotle's
Nicomachean ethics and look at his
definition of courage to think that
that's going to get you through a scary
situation when you get into the scary
situation even if you have like written
down on your hand courage is the right
amount of fear and confidence by the
time you actually look at that you know
whatever scary thing is happening is
happening you're gonna stand up to it or
not that's why habits are really
essential but we have we have to choose
our habits if we just allow ourselves to
be kind of pushed around by our society
or you know whatever other you know
determinants are taking place we're
probably not going to turn out to have
good character good character requires
you to make some choices probably
requires you to make some sacrifices too
it's not something easy to do
so that's where we'll leave a lot it's
good to play next class we're going to
do we're going to look at particular
virtues and vices one by one what do
they actually wrong what are they entail
I've got few animals up for you about
some of them like temperance liberality
magnificent someone up for anger later
today